un chilogrammo di pancetta macinata
abbastanza grassa
1,2 kg
la salsa soia chiara
politano cipolle o cipollotti mezzo
chilo due uova
le chiamate per
ancora di patate vabbè andiamo a
prenderli vai
[Musica]
io sono entrate parigi da questo mercato
sto parlando con tutti sto scoprendo che
esiste la cattura del perù
[Musica]
ci manca il glutammato il vino cinese le
uova
[Musica]
ciao ragazzi benvenuti nella puntata di
cucina buttata oggi sono qui con il
maestro della cucina cinese su internet
eric young eric grazie spesso abbiamo
copiato delle tue ricette in realtà
abbiamo già fatto i ravioli e poi ce
n'erano altre volevamo rubarti però poi
ci sono detti rubiamo direttamente tempo
e facciamoci spiegare come fare
veramente di ravioli oggi grazie a eric
perché almeno rischiamo di non morire
america invece in che modo io posso
utilizzare questi sul mio cugino non ti
piace qualcuno basta lanciare
né ai 7
[Musica]
allora partiamo cos'è la prima cosa da
fare la prima cosa prepariamo subito la
farina 1.200 grammi di farina mezzo
litro di acqua caldi na sa che dentro
l'acqua quanto
53 anni più o meno a circolare che sei
un bilancino ma come lo vediamo vediamo
questo momento della verità è vai
proviamo
mamma mia sono sei grammi ma per puzza
ottimo livello ma convinto talenti si
voi non lo sapete ma in tutto questo
eric tuo è un ristorante che si trova in
via della pista na 30 quindi se volete
assaggiare quello che faremo oggi potete
sudate e mezza goccia andare
direttamente da eric va bene procediamo
scusa
hai ragione facciamo un buco mettiamo
l'acqua dentro
non si ragazzi io oggi sono veramente
tipo bisturi la mentalità è questa più o
meno tagliati
questo è un po ruvido ma dopo mezz'ora
impastate viene da più liscio e poi
aspettare un attimo nazionale invece
all'interno i compiti a tardi c'è il che
venne cambiato viene sostituita price
mezz'ora ora farà lievitare dobbiamo
passare ripiano partiamo prima di tutto
da vedere creatura molto peggio
di questo pezzo giuro
ok però con calma è troppo stai tre
ragazzi sono inter c'è sono
ma questa è la cosa più bella di tutte
da un certo bellissimo traguardo
ma possono guardare così mentre lo
faccio è vero il riso alla cantonese in
realtà non esiste in realtà sia adattato
in lista ho saltato con solo uovo stanza
o fan e si è adattato qua perché ci
hanno visto che non mi piacciono
prosciutto e piselli
bravissimo voglio tutti i tre tutti
paghiamo sedano con 100 grammi 600
grammi di diciamo a senato dobbiamo
andare a togliere anche la parte del
foglia perché la foglia è un po amara
e arrivo la mattina questo uno dei
trucks dettagli ac parlottano un piacere
sa quale bagnare il coltello e poi
tagliare in direzione così verso gli
altri questo
noi siamo invece la tecnica
senza non cerchiamo di taglia più
possibile storia scura su 50 grammi soia
chiara un tool 20 grande più o meno
quanto 5 g grazie la zona
lo so lo so lo so occhio sono contento 5
grammi fida del piano emessi 6 erika
finale ok adesso cresciuta molto in
faccia mi piaceva si infilino stato
subito alla mescita 25 prende dovrebbe
bastare la stringa 20 g g xvi sa che lo
stava per dire io 20
più
blu luogo vado subito questa è la
sicurezza perché sai dove se casca cosa
mettiamo la verdura non c'è spazio
gianmarco perché non è
bellissimo ora il momento clou
come dita più umido e diventato è più
morbido prima era molto più duro
in teoria dovremmo aspettare ancora
mezz'ora noi voglio far ragionare su una
cosa stai facendo cucina buttata
cucinare un po di merda non ti va a
farina mano fratello
è una meta oppure un alto prezzo
adesso questa qua dobbiamo fare un
lavoro né quanti ne escono da sto ma non
di un chilo di farina 80 56 già fatto
avanti le due io sono messo più in
difficoltà di te eric perché a me questo
coso me patti ma io sto facendo io sto
spendendo così pare che stoffa curling
quindi io adesso così gli do questa roba
qua e poi schiaccia e ha fatto
importante sotto deve aver farina
soprano con dai la spinta dalla forza
ritiro solo così solo accompagnamento
però è bravo volevi che ti dicessi
questo beh non oggi carino allora lento
schiacciante bene
sino a lo chiedi sempre in mano e
concreti da consentire
chiaro
non è facilissima loro fan lui e o eric
bravissimi e tondo questo già
ok ripiano invece le pene un cucchiaio
per apprendere cane non riusciamo un
coltello possibilmente non tagliente ma
questo ci vuoi amare non c'abbiamo
conoscevamo e ringrazia averci sputato
in testa o andiamo avanti adesso
dobbiamo prendere così la forma proprio
così non può aprirlo così con la parte
non tagliante se non buttiamo d'avvio lo
mettiamo come troppo facciamo così e poi
gli schiacciamo per bene la parte di at
rome per sé un po più alto davanti
prezzo sempre questa posizione però così
dove sto a fare qua puoi mettere la tua
faccia in prospettiva adesso con questo
dito di dare un assegno fai così e
chiudi e con questo qua gli deve
spingere un pochetto a questo pezzo la
spinta o vicino molti di spinge un
pochetto chiudi spicci e che per questo
spinge questo dito chiude e quello falla
la grinza insomma
ma guardano
allora insieme
quasi mettiamo mettiamola confronto con
l'altro
ecco uguali ma posso dire che sei stato
bravissimo per fare questo risultato ci
mettono a meno cinque volte a imparare
io posso anche chiudo occhio chiuso va
meglio di sé più coraggio quando a lilla
con
erika non aver fatto il passo più lungo
della gamba
erika che ci vuole
mai stare andando benissimo e ray
bello
ara raga poteva finire molto peggio
comunque dai al volo ci facciamo gli
ultimi andiamo veloci in cottura
tecniche per cuocere al vapore pentola
con l'acqua calda qua sotto vi lasciamo
il infobox sia tutte quante le misure
diciamo gli ingredienti un recap più
facile in modo che senza dovete
ricredervi il video e allo stesso tempo
di lasciare un pochino dell'inca
affiliati per comprare
lo metto sul legno o devo coprirlo con
qualcosa possiamo fare i due modi o con
un'aperta dura la foglia oppure possiamo
gustare la teglia per barbecue ma usa
non aver dato conto ce l'abbiamo fatta
sì perché a te io per i barbecue già
stava piangendo dove tirarla fuori
aspetta partiamo quindi a mettere i miei
ma ne facciamo chirurgica ma enorme
il condimento che ribatte un orario ma
si può fare una nostra serie morendo sì
ma dobbiamo cambiare un po di cose
allora sai che ti dico fatecelo sapere
nei commenti se volete la sfida del
raviolo ne
calcola che invece di fare così tutti fa
così praticamente
quindi da quando bolle quanto 15 a 10
minuti dieci minuti e prestiti e google
si timer dieci minuti
a questionari ai ragazzi utile nel
frattempo che per i timori
aumentano le verità vediamo
però osservare che sei di bravi ora
cotton del vedere qualche uscita salsa
di soia mamma mia
allora però questi sono i tuoi giusto i
tuoi non sono una merda midiri tuoi
[Musica]
per cui senza salsa nel niente
sapete volevano strana che ovviamente sì
come hai fatto tu ripiene del proprio
come quello del ristorante come sono
pazzeschi
i ravioli appena fatti più boni a fare
questi ravioli assaggiarli è facilissimo
potete seguire la ricetta che abbiamo
fatto qui potete seguire il canale di
eric nel quale oltre ai ravioli fa
vedere un sacco di atene diretta oppure
se non volete pop alzare una palina che
sia una potete andare la corona
magnifica in via la pisana 39 cioè in
questo modo gli serviamo noi ha detto
ciò ci vediamo domenica prossima alle 12
con una puntata di cucina buttata ciao
con gli si dice ciao in saluto e tiene a
fare quello
no
[Applauso]
[Musica]